مع وصول عدد الضحايا في تركيا وسوريا الى
قرابه 37 الف قتيل في اليوم الثامن
للزلزال تحول التركيز الان على جهود اغاثه
الناجين بعد تضاؤل الامال في انتشال احياء
من تحت الانقاد ويبقى الوضع في سوريا صعبا
وفقا المتحدثا بسم اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر والتي اكدت للعربيه ان جهود الدعم
الانساني شمال غربي البلاد متواضعه بدرجه
كبيره
[موسيقى]
للاسف الوضع المتازم والوضع الماساوي على
مستوى مدى تازم الوضع الانساني في شمال
سوريا وحول سوريا هو ليس وليدا اليوم هو
كان وضع قائم بالفعل وعلى امتداد سنوات
النزاع وخاصه على امتداد السنوات الاخيره
التي شهدت تراجع على مستوى دعم وتمويل
العمليات الانسانيه مما خلق مزيد من
الاحتياجات الطارئه خاصه في مناطق
الشماليه في سوريا اليوم نتحدث حول سوريا
هناك 15 مليون شخص من بين 18 مليون مجموعه
سكانهم في حاجه الى شكل من اشكال المساعده
الانسانيه وبالتالي ما يحصل اليوم على
خلفيه الزلزال المدمر هو فقط تواصل لازمه
انسانيه كانت قائمه بالفعل ما يقدم اليوم
نقدمه اليوم كلجنه دوليه للصليب الاحمر
بالشراكه مع شريكنا الاساسي في سوريا وهو
الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري هو هو مجهود
متواضع بالمقارنه الى ما يحتاجه السكان
فعليا ومن الضروره ان تتضافر كل جهود
لتقديم المزيد من عمليات
الاغاثه الانسانيه في الاسابيع وفي فترات
القادمه
[موسيقى]
الله
وصفات لجنه تحقيق الدوليه المستقله بشان
سوريا الاستجابه لطلب ارسال المساعدات الى
شمال غربيل البلاد بالبطيئه بشكل مميت
واكدت اللجنه انه يجب التغلب على جميع
العقبات البيروقراطيه او السياسيه او
القانونيه لانقاذ الارواح مشدده على
الحاجه الماسه لضخ مزيد من المساعده
انا نازح مغيب من دير من اربع سنوات
فجاه اجا صار زلزال الساعه ثلاثه ثلاثه
ونصف اربعه بالضبط ما بعرف
نهدد البناي انجرح واحد من عندي من
الاولاد
الجرحى معبينا الشوارع الشهداء اللي شافت
دمارك كتير بنايات لبينا نداء انه في مخيم
ايواء لانه اخواننا المضرين كثيرين وعم
نعمل اللي بقدر الله عليك وسبحان الله انه
الجو برد مع كل هالبرد لبينا نداء
واخواننا انا نازح بحس بموعات راح بيته
عنده ماوى يعني
لله الامر الحمد لله وين هلا عم نسمع يعني
عم يلبي اخواتنا ان شاء الله وبتمنى من كل
واحد يعني قادر على العمل يعني يذهب بشكل
تطوعي
ويساعد اخواتنا
طلبت مديره صندوق النقد الدوليه المجتمع
الدولي بتقديم المساعده لسوريا اثر
الزلزال الذي ضربها وصرحت خلال القمه
العالميه للحكومات ان سوريا التي تعاني
اصلا بحاجه لمساعده فوريه مضيفه انه لا
يمكن للناس الانتظار عده ايام وذلك ردا
على سؤال حول ضروره تخفيف العقوبات
اعلنا ياسر طرافه منسقه الاستجابه الطارئه
بالجمعيه الدوليه لرعايه الكوارث والذي
يعمل في مخيم الاغاثه السعودي في جنديرس
في شمال غربي سوريا اعلن مبادئ عمليات
توزيع المساعدات السعوديه التي وصلت من
مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه في جنديرس طبعا
بدايه بحب اذكر انه اول شيء هذه الطائره
دخلت من خلال معبر جوي اغاثه بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبين تركيا طبعا هذه
الطائرات دخل منها الى سوريا قافيه واحده
اللي هي عباره عن 11 شحنه بقيه الحملات
حيث يتم توزيعها بين سوريا وبتركيا
بالنسبه للجانب السوري فاللي دخل هو عباره
عن 11 شاحنه من خلال معبر الحمام الحلول
مع تركيا هاي الشواحين تتضمن عده مواد
اللي هي مواد غذائيه خلال غذائيه ومواد
غير غذائيه اللي هي طبعا كانت عباره عن
خيم وسلال ايواء واغطيه
الناس اللي ضررت يؤثر الزلزال الي صار
جنوب بتركيا او شمال سوريا طبعا هاي
المواد
بمناطق ادلب ومناطق عفرين متواجدين بيه
وسط من ناحيه جنديرس عم نقوم ببناء واحد
المخيمات طبعا هذا المخيم رقم ثلاثه اللي
احنا عم نباشر فيه ان شاء الله وغدا فرقنا
راح تكون متواجده بمناطق ادلب لا ان شاء
الله رب العالمين حنحاول لاكبر عدد ممكن
من الناس اللي ضررت خلال الفتره القادمه
الخيام ولكن التجهيزات هنا تخوننا دائما
التجهيزات الانترنت صعوبه التواصل تخوننا
دائما في الدخول بين الاهالي ولكن في
النشرات القادمه سندخل بين الاهالي
سنستضيفهم طبعا كما تلاحظون على شاشه
الكاميرا هناك العديد من العوائل التي اتت
الى هنا تنتظر الانتهاء من بناء هرجه
الحراره هنا ناقص درجتان اغلب هؤلاء
الاهالي كانوا يبيتون في مراكز الايواء
المؤقته منهم من كان يبيت امام منزله
المدمر بشكل جزئي يخاف دخوله نتيجه يعني
وجود هزات ارتداديه تحدث بين الحين والاخر
عود مجددا الى جنديرس والصحافه محمد
الاشقر محمد كنا نتحدث قبل قليل عن هذه
البقعه الجغرافيه الصغيره او او هي ليست
بصغيره ولكنها اصلا كانت تحوي اعداد كبيره
من اللاجئين من مختلف المناطق السوريه بعد
الحرب في الشمال السوري تحديدا اليوم مع
هذا الزلزال ايضا نزحت اعداد اضافيه
وبالتالي مخيمات اضافيه واقع انساني صعب
كيف يتم تنسيق بناء هذه المخيمات هل تراعى
فيها اي معايير من قبل يعني ان كان
المنظمات غير الحكوميه او يعني الامم
المتحده او الجهات التي تساعد على الارض
نعم يعني الان يتم العمل
يعني
لاسعاف والتنفيذ استجابه طارئه لتلك
العوائل المتضرره بسبب ارتفاع اعدادها
هناك الاف العوائل المتضرره التي الى حد
هذه اللحظه لا تزال بلا ماوى يعني اليوم
الذي كنا فيه تم نصب اكثر من مئه وخمسه
وعشرين خيمه تم تسليمها بشكل مباشر لعوائل
متضررين وسيتم استكمال واستئناف توزيع
الخيم
للاهالي المتضررين بالاضافه لاستئناف
توزيع السلل الاغاثيه والسلل الغير غذائيه
مثل مستلزمات الخيمه وما يلزم العوائل من
اغطيه واسفنجات وغيرها من مستلزمات الخيمه
طبعا بشكل عام المنظمات الانسانيه المحليه
والفرق التطوعيه يعني منذ ساعات
الكارثه الاولى وهي تستنشر طاقاتها طبعا
قبل دخول هذه المساعدات جميع ما قدم هو من
ضمن مخزون هذه
المنظمات والشرق والمخصصات الشهريه
للنازحين سكان الخيام يعني
الان
الاولويات لدى الجميع هي
يعني عن المئات من الخيم التي يتم تشييده
وبناء ولكن الحاجه والنقص هي الى اي عدد
اليوم
محمد ما زلت معي نعم تعيد السؤال كنت
اتحدث عن هذه المنطقه التي هي اصلا منكوبه
منذ ما قبل هذه الكارثه اليوم هناك
استجابه وهناك مساعده من قبل الدول
العربيه وهي الاساسيه بظل يعني الاستجابه
الضعيفه للامميه محمد ابقى معي لو سمحت
سنتابع هذه الصور التي وردتنا لانقاذ رجل
في هاتاي التركيه من تحت الانقاض بعد
183 ساعه
اذا هذه الصور المباشره نقلا عن وسائل
الاعلام التركيه
لانقاذ رجل من مدينه هاتاي التركيه بعد
اكثر من مئه وعشرين ساعه اذا هذه الصور
الاوليه التي وردتنا والتي يعني بثت قبل
قليل لعمليه الانقاذ على امل ان يكون بصحه
جيده
وان لا يكون هناك اي اصابه
بعد يعني كوثي اكثر من اسبوع ان نتحدث عن
ثمانيه ايام اكثر من اسبوع تحت الانقاض لا
معلومات طبعا حتى ساعه عن عمر هذا الرجل
ولكن اذا الامل مازال موجود بعد
ثمانيه ايام من حصول هذا الزلزال بالرغم
من انه يعني ببعض الاوقات الياس يسيطر على
المتابعين على رجال الانقاذ ولكن كل كم
ساعه نحن ننقل خبر جيد وخبر يعني مفرح
بوجود
ناشين تحت هذه الالقاد بعد الز المدمر
الذي ضرب عشر ولايات تركيا طبعا والمناطق
مناطق شمال سوريا لمزيد من التفاصيل حول
عمليه الاغاثه هذه ينضم الينا منها
عمار الهندي عمار هل لديك اي تفاصيل عن
هذه العمليه انا
حتى اللحظه لا عن عمليه انقاذ هذا الرجل
لا اسمعها منك وفرحت كثيرا ولكن كنت علمت
ايضا بان هنالك طفلين خرجان من تحت
الانقاض ولديهم اسره تتواجد هنا وكنا
نتابعها منذ الصباح وبالتالي هذه معجزات
ليال تحدث ولا زلنا في مركز ايواء
السوريين الفارين من الدمار الهائل فيها
تاي هذه السيده سمعتنا ونحن على الهواء
وكما تعلمين ليال القصص كثيره والحكايه
كثيره ونحاول ان نستمع الى اكبر قدر ممكن
من الحكايه والقصص تحياتي اختي انت كان
بدك تحكي لنا شيء واحنا على الهواء ايش
المشكله
طيب ممتاز ايش المشكله الان يعني انت بدك
بيت اه بدك خيمته بدي بيت نبرك يعني
انت عائلتك جميع سالمة ما في الحمد لله
طيب جربتي في المخيم المجاور انه تسالي
ماذا قالوا لك
بخيمه يعني المشكله ان شاء الله انحلت
يعني خيمتين بدنا ان شاء الله طيب انتوا
راح تسكنوا مؤقتا هون تبقوا هون ولا راح
تنتقلوا
قدران نطلع لبره
العيال المشاكل كثيره جدا طبعا وشكاوى
كثيره جدا بانه بطبيعه الحال الوضع لا
ابرره ولكن نعم
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ان
شاء الله المشكله ستحلل ان شاء الله
نحن نحاول فقط ان نرصد اكبر عدد ما ترصده
هنا الحلال بهذه بمخيمات حالات انسانيه
صعبه وطبعا هناك يعني عوز كبير من قبل
هؤلاء بعد ما خسروا كل شيء نحن نتحدث يعني
عن ان اغلبيه اليوم المنكوبين هم من
الطبقه الوسطى ومادون وبالتالي يعني طبيعي
الصوره التي تنقلها من هناك خصوصا انهم
منهكين بعد كل ما مروا به عمار يعني ايضا
بمراكز الايواء التي كنت قد اجريت جوله
بها اليوم ما هي اكثر الاحتياجات الموجوده
بهذه المراكز خصوصا ان يعني ما رصدته
الحكومه التركيه من مساعدات داخليه
وخارجيه هو اكبر بكثير مما هو موجود بشمال
سوريا
صحيح انا اعتقد ان المساكن هي اكبر حاجه
لهم هؤلاء طبعا فقدوا كل شيء حتى الملابس
يعني هنا ساجول في الكاميرا وتشاهدي ليال
ما الذي يحدث هنا هنالك طبعا ملابس هذا
مركز ايواء بسيط يعني مجموعه من المتبرعين
مجموعه من المتطوعين قاموا بانشاء هذا
المركز يعني الناس تاتي الى هنا لديها فقط
ما تلبسه في في رحلتها وليس لديها ملابس
اخرى هذه اذا كانت الصوره توضح هذه ملابس
هنا تاتي الناس ويعني تحاول ان تجد ما
يناسبها من ملابس
للدفء وللعيش وهذا هو الحال هنا يعني
فهمتي علي لا وجود يعني لا وجود لاي
مساعدات هذه مثلا مواد غذائيه بسيطه هذا
مطبخ يقوم يعني هنا باعداد الطعام
للنازحين الاتيين من المناطق المدمره
الامكانيات بسيطه حتى المركز يعني الطبي
العي الطبيه هم قاموا يعني بجمع ادويه
مستخدمه من منازل متبرعين في المدينه في
المنطقه هنا ويستخدمونها للعلاج هنا
البسيط وكنت سالت مدير هذا المركز عن
صلاحيه هذه الادويه وخطرها واكد لي ان
هنالك طبيب متطوع ايضا ياتي هنا لزياره
هذا المركز والاشراف على اعطاء الادويه
يعني امكانيات بسيطه هنالك حاجيات كثيره
مطلوبه نعم عمار يعني حسب ما هو معلوم
بانه لدى السلطات التركيه بما اننا نتحدث
عن دوله بالمعنى الحقيقي لديها يعني خطه
استجابه للطوارئ بحال بحال يعني وقوع
الكوارث الانسانيه وخصوصا بموضوع الخيم
وموضوع
الامدادات والاغاثه اتحدث عن الطعام هنا
هل هي كافيه لمعظم يعني انت تنقل صوره
بانها غير كافيه نهائيا هل هذا هو الحال
بكل المخيمات التي يعني اجريت جوله
على العكس انا كنت زرت مخيمات اخرى بعيده
لاباد موجود فيها الطعام موجود فيها الماء
موجود فيها الخيام ولكن انا اتحدث الان
هنا عن المجتمع السوري النازح يعني هم
جاؤوا الى هذا المركز طبعا سيتبادر اليك
سؤال انه هل هنالك تمييز في التعامل انا
لا اقصد ان هنالك تمييز ولكن سمعت شكاوى
كثيره يعني سمعت من سوريين شكاوى بان
هنالك يعني عدم تعاون معهم كامل فيما يخص
مسالتهم وان يعني هنالك حاجات لهم لا تلبى
سريعا وحتى في مجال الانقاذ حتى في ميجاء
مجال انتشال الجثث في كثير من الامور في
شكاوى عديده انا سمعتها وشاهدت بعيني
ويعني رايت اشخاص يقفون امام مباني
ينتظرون يعني احد الاشخاص هذا السؤال عمار
عمار على كل حال
على كل حال عمار سنتابع معك التغطيه ونقل
الصوره من هناك وتحديدا المخيم بعد قليل
شكرا لك عمار الهندي من هاتاي التركيه
وشكرا لك ايضا صحافي محمد الاشقر من
جنديرس
[موسيقى]
قال مسؤول بالخارجيه الالمانيه ان
العقوبات الاوروبيه على سوريا لا تشمل
مساعدات الانسانيه او الالات الثقيله
الخاصه بعمليه الالقاد واشار المسؤوليه
الى ان الاتحاد ساعد السوريين على مدار
الاثنتي عشره سنه الماضيه بمساعدات قيمتها
11 مليار يورو
هذا وقال المبعوث الامامي الى سوريا انه
استمع الى تطمينات من الحكومه السوريه
بشان العمل في جميع انحاء البلاد لتقديم
الدعم للمتضررين من الزلزال مضيفا عقب
لقائه بوزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل مقداد
بان التركيز سينصب على الدعم من خلال
المعابر الحدوديه
ستبذل الامم المتحده كلما في وسعها لدعم
الشعب السوري في هذه الازمه كما اكدنا على
ضروره العمل في جميع مناطق سوريا وساعدت
بسماع تطمينات من الحكومه السوريه بانها
ستدعمنا في العمل الذي نقوم به في جميع
انحاء البلاد لانه كما نعلم جميعا كان
هناك تحد خاص فور وقوع الزلزال للحصول على
الدعم في شمال غرب سوريا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من عمان الناشطه
السياسي السوري احمد المسالمه استاذ احمد
بما اننا نتحدث عن الاستجابه الامميه
تحدثنا عنها طبعا قبل هناك تصريح يقول بان
امدادات الطبيه اليوم
لسوريا وتحديدا لشمال سوريا والمناطق
المنكوبه لا تغطي احتياجات 20% من السكان
المتضررين اين هي الصحه العالميه من هذا
التصريح وخصوصا اننا نتحدث عن ان من نجى
من الزلزال من المحتمل ان لا ينجو من
تبعات الصحيه لما بعد الزلزال في حال عدم
وجود يعني
امدادات صحيحه وايضا مستشفيات قادره على
تلبيات هؤلاء
اي نعم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
ان لسنا ميتين فنحن لسنا بخير هكذا ينظرون
الينا انا لاننا نموت فنحن بخير هذا الامر
سيء جدا الامور في الشمال الغربي من سوريا
العمليات التي تتم المساعدات التي دخلت لا
تلبي نسبه عشرين الى اقل من 20% من حجه
الاهالي مشى في ميدانيه غير موجوده
المراكز الصحيه والمراكز الطبيه غير
متوفره الزلزال اتى على الكثير من النقاط
الطبيه وعن على حتى العيادات الخاصه
للاطباء التي لفقدوا كل شيء الان الاهالي
بدون ماوى هو الاهم والافضل في هذه
الاونه هو العمل على ايجاد ماوى لجمع
الاهالي من تحت الاشجار ومن الطرقات
ووضع مخيمات وقرفانات وكل ما يساعد على
ايواهم اما اذا نظرنا الى الجانب الطبي
والصحي فانه هناك كثير من الاطباء وصلوا
بجهود شخصيه جهود فرديه من عده دول الى
الشمال الغربي من سوريا ودخلوا ويقومون
بالعمل ومتابعه العمل الطبي ولكن قله
التوفر المستلزمات والمستهلكات الطبيه
والاجهزه الطبيه بين ايديهم يؤدي الى
الكارثه زياده هذه الكارثه فنحن نطالب
بوصول المعدات الثقيله لرفع الانقاذ وايضا
وصول المساعدات الطبيه
الملحه من من الاسعافات الاوليه والتي
تساعد في هذه الامور وايضا ايجاد الماوى
صريعا وايجاد المكان لايواء الجرحى وانشاء
المشافي الميدانيه وهذا المتطلب يجب ان
يكون من
المنظمه منظمه الصحه العالميه التي قالت
يوم امس بمؤتمر صحفي بانه تريد ان تدخل
الى الشمال السوري وتدير ان تدخل بكل
المناطق المنكوبه من الزلزال ولم نسمع
منهم الا التصريعات الى هذه اللحظه الذي
وصل هو عده شاحنات هذه الشاحنات لا تغطي
من 15 الى 20% فقط من المستلزمات ولا تكفي
عده ايام وهنا السؤال الكبير الذي يتم
سؤاله الى المنظمات الدوليه التي عملت في
الشمال السوري 12 عاما وانتم تعملون اين
مخزوناتكم اين
ذهبت هذه الامور التي لا يوجد لديكم
مستودعات
لمده اسبوع ان تتمكن من مده اسبوع
الشاحنات التي تصل لا تكفي المهجرين
والذين احدث عندهم مناطق الزلزال وجبه
واحده في اليوم
استاذ احمد طبعا هذا السؤال ضروري وسالناه
منذ اليوم الاول لهذه الكارثه خصوصا واننا
نتحدث عن منطقه اصلا لديها هشاشه بالبنيه
التحتيه
بالبناء على كافه المستويات نحن اليوم
ننتقل تدريجيا من مرحله الانقاذ الى مرحله
الايواء والاستشفاء وبالتالي مستلزمات
اساسيه طبعا كنت تحدثت عنه وهي موضوع
الخيم وغير من
يعني ما المطلوب اليوم بشكل الاساسي على
الارض لكي لا يكون مصير من نجوا من
الزلزال هو الموت ايضا
الان الحاجه الملحه الى
كرفانات هذه الكرفانات ليست
بالتكلفه الكبيره اقل من الف دولار ثمن
هذه الكرفانات عندما يتم جمع المساعدات ان
تتوجه هذه المساعدات الى الكرفانات لانها
تقي الان الاهالي من البريد وتقيهم من
البقاء في العراء وايضا وجود الخيم وتوزيع
الخيم في هذه المناطق وعندما يكون هناك
الماوى
الامور الاخرى تاتي تباعا ايضا يجب ان
يكون هناك المعدات الثقيله لرفع الانقاذ
بصوره بشكل اكبر
ليتمكنوا من فتح اعاده احياء هذه المنطقه
ان لم بقينا على هذه الشاكله فالامور
ستزداد سوءا نحن مثل عشره عامه الى هذه
اللحظه لم نشاهد اي جسم معين حتى جسم
معارض كبير ليحمي هذه المنطقه او ليتحدث
باسم هذه المنطقه او يكون ذخرا لهذه
المنطقه يساند لها كثر المنظمات الدوليه
كثر الفصائل العامله كثر على الشخصيات
التي تعمل في الداخل السوري حتى باتفاقنا
نحن مختلفون بكل اسف حتى باتفاقنا نحن
مختلفون وهذا الامر ادى الى هذه الكوارث
الان نحن بحاجه الى ايواء بحاجه الى خدمات
طبيه بحاجه الى فرق انقاذ تساعد على
انتشال ما تبقى من الجثث حتى يتم دفنها
وتكريمها بالدفن شكرا لك استاذ احمد
المسالم ما حدثنا من عمان
حنان ناجيه سوريا بقيت تحت الانقاض فيها
طاي لايام تروي للعربيه قصه نجاتها وتقول
ان شعور الخوف لم يفارقها حتى بعد خروجها
من تحت الانقاذ وهي تشعر الى الان باهتزاز
الارض الذي لم يتوقف وفق روايتها
اقعد
بصرختز
بركي والله وحاسه انه الارض عم بتهز فيا
وعم بصيح انا ثلاثه ايام رقم من جنبي عالم
ما حد بيطلع حدا وانت تصرخي وما حد يسمعك
انا بدي اسمع انا بدي اسمع هذه التجربه
ولو انها يعني دموعك
عم تشوفون قدامي عم بشوفهم المطر عم تنزل
علينا
بس انا صاحي بعدها نهار ما بعرف شو صار
مطر تحت المطر والبرد والصدر
راح صوتك
الحمد لله لا الحمد لله يعني هون
شوي شوي الحمد لله
طيب ثلاث ايام اللي عشتيها تحت الانقاض
انت لديك تجربه مرعبه يعني انا اعرف
واعتذر باركي هون الصراحه وخايفه طب ايش
بدون ما عطشتي جعتي ايش ايش اللي شعرت فيه
البرد
من انقذك كيف صارت عمليه الانقاذ ما صار
العالم يجوا يعملوا هيك في واحد تركي كتر
خيره
اجا شافني
3 ايام
معنا عضو مجلس اداره الدفاع المدني احمد
يازجي استاذ احمد يعني كيف هي الصوره من
هناك بعد ما دخلت بعض المساعدات الانسانيه
من معبر باب الهوى
لاي مدى النقص ما زال كبير والى اي مدى
الواقع ما زال يعني مزرب المناطق الشماليه
من سوريا
بالنسبه للمساعدات التي وصلت الى شمال غرب
سوريا هي الحد الادنى من الاحتياجات
الاساسيه ان كانت للمدنيين او ايضا لفرق
الدفاع المدني الذي لا زالت الان متواجده
في الاماكن التي تعرضت للبرر بالاضافه
ايضا موجوده في الاماكن التي كان يوجد بها
مفقودين تحت الالفاظ
الان الارقام تشير انه الى حد هذه اللحظه
اغلب الفرق
ابلغتنا انه لا يوجد اي شخص تحت الانقاذ
اذا الى حد هذه اللحظه ولكن الفرق
المتواجده في الاماكن التي خصصت لها في
الاماكن التي تعرضت ايضا
الانهيارات في حال وجود اي
مدني ان كان غائبا عن الموقع وعاد ويريد
ان
يتطمن عن اقاربه
بامكانه
اخبار الدفاع المدني لكي يتم التواصل مع
ان كان مع المسافه او حتى مديريات صحن
لابلاغه اين يوجد هذا الشخص استاذ احمد
يعني اذا ما قارنا الارقام الرسميه
التركيه عن مراكز الايواء عن المخيمات
نتحدث عن مئات المخيمات التي شيدت بالايام
الماضيه نتحدث عن استجابه كبيره وبالرغم
من ذلك هناك بعض الانتقادات الداخليه يعني
الصوره المغايره بشمال سوريا كيف هي
ما في اي مقارنه بين الجانب التركي
والجانب السوري
من حيث المساعدات فان قلنا عن جانب السوري
في شمال غرب سوريا فلا يوجد بالاساس اي
مراكز عباره كان
الفتره الايام الماضيه هي عباره عن
مبادرات مدنيه بعض المحاليل التجاريه فتحت
محالها بالاضافه الى ايضا المطاعم اغلقت
واصبحت مراكز ايواء يوجد للان بعض مراكز
ايواء ولكن بسيطه جدا بمقومات
طبعا ليس للمقارنه لان لا مجال للمقارنه
هناك نتحدث عن دوله كامله المعالم
والادارات هنا نتحدث عن عن يعني عن تقسيم
رهيب عن خارطه سياسيه رهيبه ولكن اسال
لننقل الحاجه السوريه هناك بشمال سوريا
الى اي مدى هناك حاجه كبيره وملحه لمراكز
ايواء لمخيمات طبعا الزملاء قبل قليل
وفونا بهذه الصوره ولكن انتم كدفاع مدني
ما الذي رصدتموه على الارض
متواجد اربعين الف عائله هي الان بلا ماوى
وهي بحاجه الى مراكز لاحتواء هؤلاء
العوائل بالاضافه ايضا صدمه حوالي 11 الف
مصاب يحتاجون الى رعايه صحيه والى التضارب
والى ايضا مشاكل ميدانيه لمتابعه علاجه
الاحتياجات كبيره جدا جدا جدا على مقارنه
بحجم الفارسه وما يزيد المعاناه هو قدوم
تسامين الاشخاص من تركيا الى سوريا
اعلن المعبر القدوم حوالي 1200 دسمان
لاشخاص فقدوا فقدوا حياتهم في تركيا
وهم دخلوا الى الاراضي السوريه مما زاد
معاناته ماساه المدنيين المتواجدين
شاهدنا السيارات التي دخلت يعني هم هربوا
من الموت وعادوا للاسف اموات مجددا الى
هناك يعني صوره ماساويه بدرجه لا يمكن
وصفه استاذ احمد يعني من المعلوم حتى ولو
ليس رسمي انكم تلقيتم عدد كبير من
المساعدات الخارجيه كاداره دفاع مدني
بادلب ما المطلوب ايضا واكثر اليوم لكي
تقوموا بكل يعني ادائكم وايضا لكي تساعدوا
باكبر قدر ممكن بظل هذه الكارثه الكبيره
التي تحل بشمال سوريا
ان نقول هذه الكلمه ولكن هذا هو الحاصل
بالنسبه للمساعدات
للمدنيين المتضررين يوجد هناك مساعدات من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وصلت بالاضافه
الى دوله قطر وقرد السان العراق هذه
المساعدات فعلا هي وصلت من قبل هذه الدول
ووصلت الى مستحقيها ووصلت بعض المساعدات
من مبادرات شعبيه واهليه ولكن على مستوى
الامم المتحده الى الان لم يتم ايصال اي
مساعدات طارئه وعادله متعلقه بهذا الزلزال
بالاضافه انه وضع المعابر ايضا ما زال على
حاله شكرا لك من ادلب عضو اداره الدفاع
المدني الاستاذ احمد ياسيشي
يا الله ساعدنا يا رب انا اسف على كل شيء
يا رب
من هو على قيد الحياه واخوه ووالده هم
الذين فارقوا الحياه ايضا بالاضافه الى
ثمانيه اخرين من عائلته فرق الحياه في وضع
ماساوي يمكن ان يشرحه لنا احمد الان
ونستمع اليه نادين كيف يعني شو اللي صار
معكم بالضبط
كلياتنا قدام الباب تبع البيت عشان نطلع
لبرا ننزل لتحت منظل بالبنايه بس الباب من
الزلزال ما حسن لا يفتح ولا يتحرك حاولنا
نكسره انا وخالي اللي اكبر مني بسنتين
كسرنا في حاولنا نضربه بس لكن الباب ما
وما احسننا نفتحه بقى نحن عم نحاول ضرب
فينا الزلزال الثاني وقعنا كلياتنا
بالزلزال تاني صار في هزازه قويه وهريت
البنايه كامله بالزلزال الثاني كلياتنا
نحن لما ضرب الزلزال قعدنا فوق بعض كنا
انا انا
وخالي وخالتي وستي ومرت خالي وثلاثه من
بنات خالي واخي واختي وامي وستي
كلياتنا كلياتنا واقفين قدام الباب البيت
عم نحاول نطلع بس لما ضرب الزلزال الثاني
انبطحنا فوق بعض ووعد فينا البنايه وضليت
انا بعد فتره لاحسنت اتحرك يعني ضليت
ساعتين ثلاثه احسنت اتحرك من مكاني كنت ما
اعرف شو وضعي وكان قدامي بنت وراي بنت
وقدامي اخي شفت اخي وخالي ومرت خالي وبنات
خالي كمان شفتهم كلياتهم كان قدامي وبعد
فتره حاولت اني اطلع على الساعه 12:30
وحده حاولت اني اطلع لبرا باماكن هو انا
ما طلعت الا بفضل الله طلعت من اماكن
صغيره ضيقه جدا انها تحسنت اطلع لفوق اطلب
المساعده انه اقول انه في عايشين
[موسيقى]
في مقابله مع العربيه قال المتحدث باسم
منظمه اليونيسف في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا محمد الحواري ان تداعيات الزلزال
جعلت سوريا في وضع ماساوي مشيرا الى ان
اكثر من مليون سبعمائه الف طفل سوري
يعانون من حياه غير صالحه لذلك تقييم
الموضع انهم ماساوي صعب جدا يحتاج الكثير
والكثير من التظافر والتعاون حتى نصل الى
مرحله شبه مرضيه لحال هؤلاء الناس ولا
يخفى عليكم بان المنطقه ككل هي متضرره
بسبب عدد مرات النزوح واللجوء فيها وهناك
نقص مستدام للمساعدات بل ان اكثر من مليون
و300 الى مليون و700 الف طفل في المنطقه
هم يعانون من شتى انواع الحياه الغير
الصالحه للاستمرار سواء كان بسبب فقر الدم
او التقزم او الهزال وهناك اكثر من 500
الف امراه في نصف مليون امراه من الحوامل
هم من عندهم فقر دم قبل هذه الحاله فما
بالك اليوم
مدير المرصاد السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي
عبد الرحمن الحديث
اكتب السؤال على المناطق السوريه الخاضعه
لسيطره النظام بما اننا ننقل الواقع
بالمناطق الاخرى منذ بدايه هذه الفتره
الاخباريه كيف هو الواقع هناك كيف يتم
توزيع المساعدات وهناك العديد من
المساعدات التي وصلت الى سوريا مشروطه بان
يتم توزيعها لكامل السوريين بدون تمييز
بين المناطق التي مع النظام والمناطق التي
تدعم كيف هي الصوره بهذا الموضوع
نعم مساء الخير بدون تمييز ولكن التمييز
واضح حقيقه الامر ودون تحيز لان الواقع
بان 86 طائره وصلت الى مناطق النظام حتى
تاريخه من دول عربيه عده من دول غير عربيه
كان من المفترض ان توزع على كامل ابناء
الشعب السوري عندما نرى الماده الوضع
الماساوي في شمال غرب سوريا والمساعدات
الشحيحه التي تصل الى تلك المنطقه بينما
نرى تدفق للمساعدات الى مناطق النظام دون
ان تصل الى تلك المنطقه هذه لا يوجد عداله
بالتوزيع ولكن نعود الى مناطق النظام هل
المساعدات وزعت بشكل حقيقي على مستحقيها
بشكل قطع لو كانت المساعدات منزعت بشكل
حقيقي على مستحقيها لما شاهدنا بان
استمرار الحملات الاهليه السوريه بشكل
مكثف من كامل المناطق السوريه تتجه باتجاه
حلب باتجاه اللاذقيه باتجاه حماه باتجاه
ريف اللاذقيه لم يتجه اليه شيء مثل ما
يستطيع ان ينجوا من هذا الزلزال
يعني بالنسبه للنظام هناك في قرى ذكرناها
سابقا 21 قريه لم تصل الى قوات النظام ولا
في احصائياتها وكان فيها المئات من
السوريين قتلوا ودفنوا في مناطقهم ووصلت
اليها بعد اربعه او خمسه ايام وهي قرى شرق
ادلب وريف حلب الجنوبي بالنسبه للاحصائيات
في مناطق النظام الى الان النظام يتحدث عن
1500 1600 الاحصائيات التي لدينا من
المناطق التي سيطر عليها النظام 278 على
الاقل هؤلاء المؤكدين هناك مفقودين في
مباني يعني فرق الانقاذ انهت عملها في حلب
لكن هناك مباني لا تغزال هدمت بالسنسال لا
يعلم هل كان حقيقه الامر لا يوجد فيها احد
ام كان يوجد فيها احد ولا احد يعلم من
يسكن في تلك المناطق لماذا انهت قوات
النظام او انهت الفرق الانقاذ عملها هناك
فرق انقاذ غادرت من الجزائر وارمينيا
والاردن انهت عملها وغادرت دون ان يكون
هناك انتشار يعني من هم على قيد الحياه بل
جبل انتشار الجسامين الوضع كارثي بكل معنى
الكلمه والنظام لم يرتقي لحسن المسؤوليه
في هذه
هل لدى المرصد اي عدد تقريبي يعني بعموم
المناطق ليس فقط المناطق الخاضعه للنظام
هل لديك نعم
نعم نعم في عموم المناطق المؤكدين لديناهم
5329 بشكل قطعي لكن هناك مفقودين العدد
عقد المفقودين حتى اللحظه يبلغ نحو 2000
شخص سواء في مناطق النظام او مناطق
المعارضه لان مثل ما شاهدنا على العربيه
والحدث كيف هي منطقه دمرت بشكل كبير جدا
ارتفاع المدني قال بانه عمل في 14 مبنى
بينما المباني المدمره بشكل كامل هي اكثر
من 84 مبدا يوجد مفقودين في كامل المناطق
السوريه مناطق النظام ومناطق المعارضه
العدد قد يرتفع الى 7000 لكن قضيه
المفقودين لا نستطيع الجزر بها لان هناك
من منازلهم ولا احد يعلم اين هم بطبيعه
الحال يعني عندما نتحدث عن دوله مشتته
ومفككه يعني لا يكون هناك ارقام رسميه
كامله ولكن نحن نتحدث عن الارقام
التقديريه شكرا لك رامي عبد الرحمن من
المركز والمرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
[موسيقى]
سميح وصلت اليه فرق الانقاذ امس وتمكنت من
انتشاله الا ان الصغيره فاجئهم بطلب ولا
اغرب
روح رغم ما عانته لاسبوع تحت الانقاض بقيت
متمسكه بلذه الوان الحياه ونكهتها الجميله
[موسيقى]
ايضا لنقل الصوره من على الارض مشاهدينا
من غازي عنتاب ينضم الينا مفرد العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن يعني فيها
طاي الامل ما زالا موجود ما زال موجود
وكنا شاهدنا قبل قليل عمليه انتشال
وانقاذ لشخص بعد اكثر من اسبوع على هذا
الزلزال نحن نتحدث عن ثمانيه ايام كيف هي
الصوره من غازي عنتاب
نعم ليال بالفعل فرق الانقاذ لا زالت تعمل
على كافه المواقع التي هي بدات بالعمل
عليها منذ ايام فرق الانقاذ التركيه
والدوليه التي حطت رحاله هنا في غازي
عنتاب وفي مختلف المناطق بالاضافه الى ذلك
كان هنالك تصريح من نائب رئيس التركي مع
تجدد
الاخبار والاحاديث حول متى ستتوقف هذه
الاعمال وقال بانه
انهم لن ينهون مرحله الانقاذ من المناطق
المنكوبه بدون
ادله قاطعه على عدم وجود ناجين فبالتالي
هذا يعني بان عمليات الانقاذ ستستمر حتى
الى الايام القادمه لن يتم التوقف بحسب
هذا التصريح وبحسب الفرق الانقاديه التي
شاهدناها اليوم الا بالتاكد تماما بعدم
وجود اشخاص ناجين في المواقع المختلفه
باستخدام كافه الوسائل سواء كان التقنيه
او حتى الكلاب البوليسيه المدربه على
البحث عن الاشخاص الناجين او حتى من خلال
الفرق الانقاذيه التي تعمل وتحاول من خلال
لحظات الصمت ان تستمع الى اي
الصوت لناجي في تلك المناطق الا انه وفي
اليوم الثامن بالرغم من ان عمليات الانقاذ
لازلت مستمره ولكن عمليات استمرار وجود
النازحين في الطرقات والشوارع المختلفه
اسال عنه بشكل كبير جدا انا اتواجد في احد
الطرقات الرئيسيه في غازي عنتابو كما
تشاهدين في الصوره هذا الطريق لا ادري اذا
كنت تسمعني عبد المحسن يعني هو هناك عمليه
انتقال حاليا السكان خرجوا من منازلهم
اكثر من
تفضل عبد المحسن هناك يعني
انتقاء عمليه انتقال المرحليه والتقيت
بكثير من الاشخاص اليوم في احد المخيمات
او الحدائق التي
من خلال احد الحدائق التي تواجدنا بها
اليوم نهارا
تحدثت مع المتواجدين في تلك الحدائق في
غازي عنتاب وقالوا بانهم منازلهم لم تنهدم
البعض منهم وهو لا يعرف متى متى سيعود الى
منزله يقول بانه ينتظر من السلطات التركيه
بان تقوم بعمليه فحص لمبناء وحتى ولو انه
لم يكن هنالك ضرر بشكل مباشر لهذا المنزل
ولكن عمليه الانتظار قد تستمر وتطول نظرا
لكثره المباني التي انهدمت وتحدث عن اكثر
من 5000 مبنى انهدم احياء في المناطق
المتفرقه في العشره ولايات التي ضربها
الزلزال خلافا على ان مناطق اخرى تعرضت
لزلزال دمر كافه المباني فبالتالي سيتم
اعادته الى بشكل كامل ايضا
في هذا المنظر الذي نرصده الان في احد
شوارع غازي عنتاب هذا هو المنظر لم يتغير
منذ ايام وجود اسر متفرقه في الشوارع
الرئيسيه بجانب سياراتها تبيها ليلا وتعود
مجددا الى هذه الخيمه الصغيره هذه هذه
المنطقه تحديدا يتواجد فيها ما يقارب 20
الى 30 شخص في هذه الخيمه الصغيره
ويواجهون هذا الطقس البارد جدا تحدث الان
ودرجه الحراره سالب ثلاثه المحسوسه ليالف
بالتالي درجات حراره منخفضه بشكل كبير جدا
تحدثت ايضا مع شخص سوري اليوم قال لي بانه
في المساء يواجهون معاناه كبيره جدا مع
هذه
الدرجات الحراره المنخفضه ويحاولون
التدفئه باي طريقه كانت هنا في غازي عنتاب
وفي هذه الاماكن التي يتواجد بها في
الحقيقه بدات الحياه تعود الى طبيعتها الى
حد ما مع وجود حركه قليلا في هذا الشارع
الذي نتواجد فيه الايام الماضيه لم تكن
الحركه كبيره جدا بعض السكان قرر العوده
والبعض الاخر لا زال خائف ولدي صدمات
نفسيه كبيره جدا جراء هذا الزلزال الذي
وقع في تركيا
عبد المحسن يعني انت كنت تنقل اواقع
الواقع يعني المعيشه للناس هناك ولكن ما
كنت اتحدث عنه بان هناك انتقال تدريجي من
التركيز على عمليات الاغاثه التي ما زالت
مستمره ولكن بطبيعه الحال بعد اسبوع بدا
اسبوع تنتقل تنتقل التركيز الى عمليات
الايواء والاستشفاء بشكل اساسي كنا نرصد
مع الزملاء المخيمات ومراكز الايواء
بالمناطق الاخرى كيف هي الصوره من غازي
عنتاب هل هناك يعني لماذا الناس يباتون في
الشوارع هل نتحدث عن اتراك عن
هل هناك نقص
بمراكز الايواء ام ماذا يعني خصوصا ان
هناك عالم ما يبدو او على حسب تصريحات
الحكومه التركيه هناك خطه ممنهجه للتعاطي
بهذا الموضوع
نعم في الحقيقه من خلال المؤشرات الاوليه
وانت تسير في شوارع غازي عنتاب تشاهد
الخيام
التي ليس عليها اي شعار لا شعار تركيا ولا
شعار اي منظمات دوليه او اقليميه او حتى
امميه فبالتالي هذا يعطيك مؤشر بان جميع
او الكثير ممن لم يجدوا خيام حاولوا
ايجادها بطريقه مباشره او غير مباشره
بطريقه حتى الاشتراك بهذه الخيام مع اسر
مختلفه هذه الخيمه التي هي خلفي تشترك
فيها خمسه اسر نظرا للحاجه الكبيره جدا
وتحدثت معهم قالوا بان هذه الخيمه
يتناوبون عليها كل ساعتين تاتي اسره وتدخل
وتستدفئ من في هذه الخيمه وتعود مجددا الى
السياره
اما النوم
ينتظرون متى يحين دورهم لحين يذهبوا الى
هذه القيم هذا مؤشر كبير على الحاجه
الكبيره جدا
للخيم الايوائيه التي بالاضافه الى وسائل
التدفئه التي يفتقدونها بشكل كبير جدا
فبالتالي البعض وكثيرون تفضلوا تواجد
بالاماكن العامه نظرا
لقدرتهم وامكانياتهم على اشعال النار في
الاماكن العامه خلافا للخيم المغلقه
المتواجده في الحدائق او الاماكن المتجمعه
المجمعه للاشخاص هنالك بعض الملاعب
للانديه التركيه تم تحويلها الى
مقر للايواء هنالك بعض الحدائق ايضا
بالاضافه الى تواجد كثيرين تفضلوا المكوث
بهذا المكان
للتدفئه بالنيران والاستدفاء بها نظرا
لانها تلك المواقع لا يمكن ان يتم توفير
وسائل التدفئه بها خصوصا الحدائق التي
يمنع بها اشعال النيران فبالتالي هذا على
الحاجه الكبيره جدا لازالت لعمليات
المساعدات الاغاثيه وهي لا زالت تصل في
الحقيقه من مطار غازي عنتاب في عبر
الطائرات المختلفه وايضا بالامس كان هنالك
حاجه شديده لعمليات او الاجهزه الطبيه
التي تم بالتنسيق ما بين
الجهات السعوديه التي قدمت
ان الصوت يصل متاخر لك شكرا لك عبد المحسن
الحربي من غازي عنتاب على هذه الرساله
مشاهدينا تغطيه العربيه مستمره لكارثه
الزلزال التي حلت بكل من سوريا وتركيا
والان الى الزميله ميسون نويت